taxi
hi there
zoker park please subscribe
thank you
[Music]
i'm seeing some fish in here so small
creek small lure the cardinal rule of
fishing is to match the hatch you're
trying to mimic what they eat naturally
in the environment flies and bugs and
little nymphs on the bottom
oh no get out of here
don't mess me up
i don't know that's not food
it's cramp no no no no i don't know this
is a bobber bro
ah it's a bobber head out of here
duck
city ducks
oh come on bro it's a bobber no no no i
i'm pounding it's not food i promise
it's not real it's no no it's just the
bobber the nutritional value is zero on
that thing
[Music]
oh come on
[Music]
i'm mike i can
my friends and i grew up fishing the
mean streams and rivers of philadelphia
[Music]
now i'm a professional angler
with a screaming passion
for city fishing
all it takes is a little skill and a
local let's go to show you where the
fish are biting
[Music]
austin texas is one of the most colorful
cities in america
it's famous for rock and roll
barbecue and making cowboys cool
but i'm here for the fish
i've come to the texas state capitol to
discover the city of austin's wild side
[Music]
wow
she clean talk about clear
this is barton creek
it's fed by a series of freshwater
springs
all set in a fantastic municipal park
this river is crystal clear
so i'll have to be careful because if i
can see the fish they can probably see
me too
[Music]
this is the purest kind of fishing there
is a riverbank a rod and a hook
what the hell are they
what is that
are they bass
no
it's not very often i get to see whole
schools of bass
that right there there's like a pack of
them feel like all four or five
boundaries
oh dude
so many species here in the city of
austin but this week i came to meet
three face-to-face
in each city i go to it's my mission to
catch three specific species of fish
i call them my bucket list fish
it's not gonna be easy
but they're definitely out there
somewhere
this week i'm after three texas legends
first up is a fish so rare it only lives
here in central texas
the guadalupe bass it's the state fish
of texas
i've been told this creek is a good
place to start my search
look at the size of that one
there you go
nice fish thanks man how you doing i
cannelli good to see you man what are
you doing here man i'm i'm looking at
blimps all over the place yeah there's a
lot of giants in here they're hard to
catch though these fish get so much
pressure this water is so clear it's
like an aquarium absolutely people up
and down the trails all day long that
thing makes it tough so man what are you
what are you doing here down on barton
creek in austin i'm in austin i'm here
to try to catch three different species
of fish this week man well this is a
pretty good spot right here big tree big
lay down structure down in the water you
mind if i fish no come on okay
barton creek was one of the first places
settled in the area and now it's close
to the center of town
there are guadalupe bass here if i can
just figure out which lure to use
what are you fishing with there mike i
was fishing with a weighted wacky rig
and now i went weightless weightless
yeah that's that's about the best way to
go you see one he just ate it there you
go
[Music]
good tip bro
good tip on the waitlist bro
it's not a guadalupe but this largemouth
bass is a beautiful fish
this one's got a lot of color in this
clear water you see a lot of his black
stripes
here's the interesting thing about a
largemouth
these fish are highly visual hunters
[Music]
they can see long distance and in almost
every direction
they can even see color and are extra
sensitive to red
[Music]
but they can't close their eyes bass
like most fish have no eyelids
this is amazing where we're at
traffic noise bridges people running
past
pedestrians boaters all this noise you
can catch these fish
right in the city where you live that's
special
so it's an incredible incredible species
right here in austin downtown austin all
right
goodbye
i can see why the pioneers settled on
this river it's clean and it's clear
there's so many big six pounders i've
seen there's so many big ones it's crazy
got him good one another largemouth
time to do my bit for fish education
you can touch it
it's smooth see how smooth it is nails
teeth
it's like sandpaper you'll be okay
it's cool right you want to kiss it
before i let it go no are you sure watch
you wanna try it
success
i better let this guy go
here it goes see ya
that's two largemouth in a row
i like fishing for them
but they're not on my austin bucket list
guadalupe is a different bass than a
largemouth or a smallmouth
first thing is that bar pattern across
the lateral line super bright super wide
identifiable totally different than a
large mount
and much more rare
i'm lucky i bumped into dusty because it
turns out he's a top-notch fishing guide
and he knows exactly where to find the
guadalupe bass dusty what's up man i'm
making shots i just assumed we were
gonna be fishing from the bank oh no no
what the heck is it i mean look at the
water super shallow water skinny running
boat jet drive that's what you got to
have to run this river now the reason
i'm pumped about this you said
guadalupe bass that's right i've never
caught one of these things before well
today today's the day you think today's
the day i hope so i sure hope so i can't
wait
guadalupe bass prefer flowing water to
the still water of lakes so we need to
look for him in the best current
i've met dusty under the highway 130
overpass where it crosses the colorado
river
from here it flows southeast to where it
empties into the gulf of mexico
so we're not that far outside of austin
no not at all you're gonna see jets
flying over the top of the river right
up here this is unbelievable and what
that
look at that there's a plane landing
right now right the moon you weren't
kidding we're literally behind the
airport we're right behind it
so on one side we've got an
international airport
and on the other a huge sewage plant
goes to show that even in a big city you
don't have to go far to find nature
what's the deal what are we fishing here
so there's you see the scattered rock
along the bank yeah right with with some
lay down some logs we're in about seven
feet of water right here it's got a good
drop off right off the bank guadalupe's
ought to be in here
what's funny about this lower uh
colorado
it feels like you're like in the
wilderness but we're actually still in
the city we're gonna be here go go go
check out the beaver oh look at that is
that a beaver yeah i love beaver see
we'll know if he's mad at us he'll slap
his tail at us right if he's mad
and that was a big beaver
we don't have to worry about beavers
competing with us for fish because
they're vegetarians
they eat bark twigs and leaves
they're friends to fishermen because
they create wetlands and great structure
for fish to hide in
there's plenty of structure here i'm
using different rods and different lures
to make the most of my chances the main
reason is to have multiple presentations
ready
you've got shallow water current areas
great for a little crank bait you've got
deeper pools with big rocks and logs
come on guad
come on guad
i can't believe we hadn't caught one yet
i know i can't either this is insane
dude
i've been working the bank for three
hours and not a single nibble
i'm almost out of daylight and the
guadalupe is proving to be as rare as
they say it is
my fish
oh
mine broke
right where it was supposed to be
[Music]
broke
okay so i'm not one of those guys who
fishes for relaxation my bad
but i'm sure i just lost my first ever
guadalupe bass because my line snapped
right where he was supposed to be
why did that happen any idea yes i was
just talking to myself
[Laughter]
all the deep water right here is in this
little intake
anywhere where there's looks like
there's current
we need a guade
good current coming through right here
with this sandbar coming out
that outflow pipe is creating the kind
of current guadalupe bass are attracted
to
and there goes one
got one dusty
ah
no offensive
[Applause]
wow
there you have it that's the guadalupe
bass that's the state fish of texas look
at the coloration along the lateral line
look at those
very identifiable bars
very specific to the guadalupe another
sign that this is a guadalupe if you
look at it he's got a little patch of
teeth right there on his tongue you can
see those same teeth like sandpaper all
along top and bottom
lots of fish have a tooth patch on their
tongue
it may help them drag prey down her
throat
the guadalupe bass only found in this
part of texas my first one ever and i
get to check a new species off my bucket
list that's awesome
and like i always say if you love
something
let it go
didn't love me though
dusty i i can't say enough man this is
so cool didn't know you from adam yeah
uh and you invited me out here to try to
catch guadalupe it's awesome man uh
that's proof the people of texas amazing
hospitality amazing friendship if for
some reason you're ever in philly
please let me return the favor i will do
this i'll buy a philly cheesesteak
sounds great
all this talk about cheesesteaks is
making me hungry
so where's a great place to have
something tasty in austin
can you help me with austin barbecue
what's the best where should i go go to
blacks on barton springs that's pretty
popular joint i'm from philly okay i
know cheese steaks but i don't know
barbecue so what kind of meat should i
get oh everybody says you gotta get the
brisket
barbecue is big in austin
wow
any bass no bass no sir this is terry
black's barbecue joint
it's one of the best
every day at three in the morning they
begin loading up these giant barbecues
with brisket ribs sausages and turkey
slow cooking and smoking it to texas
perfection that's no guadalupe but it
sure looks good but i'm not here for the
red meat the next fish on my bucket list
is blue
blue catfish are a popular target in the
austin area
finely honed senses
hard to catch and even harder in these
wintery conditions
we've got a hard freeze warning in
effect we are now at 53 consecutive
hours in austin of at or below freezing
temperatures
austin is freezing
the weather this week stinks
it really tanked it's super cold and the
fishing's gonna be tough
but that won't stop me because the fish
are still here
you just have to know where to find them
about an hour and a half north of austin
lies the buchanan dam
legend has it that the lake made by
buchanan dam is crazy with fish
it's late i'm tired i got to get up at 3
a.m tomorrow i'm gonna go meet my friend
clancy up at buchanan dam and we're
gonna try to catch a big blue cat
clancy hey how you doing can i come
aboard absolutely come on all right
first things first
who can i blame for this cold weather
[Laughter]
where are we at today what are we doing
we're on lake buchanan and we're going
to try to catch a big catfish is this
abnormally cold for this area is this no
yeah it's pretty abnormal can you
remember the last time you've had two
nights in a row
that were below freezing can you
remember last time that happened i
cannot you're just so lucky
okay be honest with me what are our
chances of catching a fish today
a five
it's pretty good odds fifty fifty fifty
all right let's do it
clancy knows this lake like the back of
his hand and he definitely knows catfish
but the cold weather is a problem
the body temperature of most fish
changes to closely match their
environment
the chilly catfish will probably be less
active and harder to catch
we'll need all the luck we can get
now are there any good luck catfish
songs that we should be singing i don't
know of a catfish song
[Applause]
we're going to a cove we call tora kaka
tora kaka
then that cove is a rock pile okay and
we're gonna get as close to that rock
pile as we can get drop our anchors
pitch out cut bait on the bottom and
we're gonna wait for one of them reels
to start screaming that rock pile's key
because the fish use that as an ambush
spot that's correct catfish love
structure if we're not fishing around
rocks we're fishing around trees
natural structures in the water provide
homes and hideouts
that's where i'm hoping to find my big
blue catfish
the blue cats range covers the ohio
missouri and mississippi rivers to as
far south as guatemala and they can grow
as big as 50 pounds well we're already
starting to come up on the edge of it
here clancy you want me to start
bringing it back the other way yeah just
start slowly pulling it in okay
wet hands 30 degree weather
not good
first time great how'd i do you did
great
best anchor guy i've had all day
anchor boy
you hear that every morning
what is that clancy that's coyotes
you can tell right over here
coyotes in the wild normally need up to
16 square miles of land to survive
but in urban areas like austin less than
one square mile is enough
every morning that's awesome coyotes wow
okay maybe it'll be good luck
lake buchanan is an amazing habitat but
it's not natural it's man-made
more than a century ago engineers began
damming austin's colorado river
this dam when it was built in the 1930s
was the longest multi-arch dam in the
united states at over two miles long
they created six dams that form six
lakes and they make up austin's main
waterways
these lakes are an amazing place to find
fish in the city
gotta find that cat
here kitty kitty kitty kitty you know
i've only got a week to do it doesn't
matter if it's cold i've got to catch
those three species no fish left behind
blue catfish are opportunistic predators
they hunt for other fish but will also
gobble up anything they find
like plants bugs or worms
one of their most common prey
american gizzard shad
look
shad busting out there ready they are
jumping everywhere yeah there's a lot
more activity
the sun's coming up now the shad's
starting to move out of this cove we're
seeing shad gizzard shad threadfins
busting everywhere you can go to just
about any cove on the lake
it's the same thing where the shad go in
at night and come out in the morning
they move out of that shallow water
because it's the sun comes up and
they're just like
that one right there
oh he's got it
give me slack
if he's still pulling on it let him have
it
that one right there oh he's got it if
he's still pulling on it let him have it
give him slack give him slack peel it
out peel about three foot out
he dropped it because he felt the
tension i think you're kidding me wow
that was a definite bite too it's a
frigid morning on austin's lake buchanan
so any signs of life is good but i might
have just lost my first blue catfish
yeah are you kidding me
front front right
if he's still pulling on it let him have
it
nobody
come on
he picked it back up though
that's amazing he did it again
i cannot believe this wow
they're smart we've had two bites
where literally these catfish have come
up and sucked it in peeled off with it
and then dropped it
every time i think i've got him he
disappears
oh he's got it he's going to
he's going to run away with it all right
he's got something good
i got him let's get through that cut i
got it oh guess what it is
oh that's a bass
what
that's not possible
well
hey
you know
you come catfishing maybe you should go
bass fishing you'll get the catfish
i guess somebody told the austin bass
that i'm in town cause i just seem to
keep catching them
i gotta be honest with you this is
probably the strangest largemouth i've
ever caught in my life to catch a bass
on cut bait
that that's just strange
largemouth bass are active predators
they usually hunt prey that is actually
moving like fish
shrimp snakes frogs even baby alligators
i've never heard of them trying to eat a
chunk of dead fish
it's a good start but it's not the giant
catfish that we were looking for
bye
go tell your catfish friends
i've been bass fishing my whole life
well over 30 years
and i've never ever ever have i caught a
largemouth on cut bait fishing on the
bottom
but it makes sense
we've got this major cold front we've
had two nights where the temperature's
been in the 20s and largemouth get
lethargic they slow down instead of
feeding up and chasing now they're on
the bottom and they're trying to get an
easy meal
[Music]
we've been here for four hours working
the edge of a rock pile and looking for
a bite
it's funny the difference like if i cast
10 foot that way it stinks forever if i
cast that way it stops it's a lot
shallower on top right there
clancy's fish finder uses sonar to show
us what's on the bottom of the lake
that hump is a rock pile we're fishing
drop her down drop her down
after it hits the bottom get the line
tight you know where it just starts to
grab the sinker you know and then two
cranks two cranks
what what what's that
oh nope tell me when
now
okay
get it out there
get it out i can't get it out of them
oh that's a big one guys
that's a big fish that's a giant try not
to horsey okay
i got to get these other rods up
nice all right try your best to wear him
out just nice and smooth
that is not a small fish
he's gonna dive as soon as he gets to
the boat he's gonna dive again
when the fish senses the boat it could
panic and dive or run under the boat i
can't let that happen
oh please please please that's a big
fish
my heart's pounding so bad
nice and smooth
[Music]
it is a blue
did that just happen
wow i am shaking like a leaf
catfish is considered easy a bottom
feeder doesn't fight
i got to tell you all that is incorrect
they're beautiful beautiful creatures a
lot of people think these whiskers are
poisonous they're stingers they are not
stingers
these whiskers or barbels
actually help this fish detect its food
these things pick up the scent from a
long ways away they use every part of
their body
to find their food to find that shad to
feed on it beautiful beautiful creature
[Music]
because they have to survive in murky
water blue catfish can hunt using just
taste and smell
even their skin has taste buds
like some sharks they can detect
chemicals at one part to 10 billion
parts of water
man this is what it's all about clancy
would come for a giant catfish i'd
classify this as a giant catfish
it's a good one
god it's gorgeous
thank you mrs blue cat beautiful fish
look at that
i just caught my second bucket list fish
and i got to meet up with an amazing
animal
now it's time to hit the very center of
town to fish one of austin's most iconic
fishing spots
it's a must fish destination for anyone
who comes to central texas
i'm mike iaconelli i've come to austin
texas in search of some very special
fishing
and there's one lake that i think
everybody should fish at least once
this is lady bird lake but the locals
call it town lake
it was officially renamed lady bird lake
because of lady bird johnson
it used to be a system for a power plant
trash
all over the place dirty banks lady bird
came in and cleaned it up and it's the
beautiful lake it is today
duke
this is duke kinley who's a
record-setting angler around austin
he's going to take me fishing on this
historic waterway
just for today i'm after an eight-pound
largemouth bass my specialty but not a
bucket list fish
man i'm excited we're here in downtown
austin we're gonna catch fish that's
pretty awesome now the water's clear is
the water always as clean is this normal
no this is not normal that cold weather
has changed the whole dynamics of the
water right now yeah we just had some
rains and you that gets muddied up yeah
but right now this is
it's looking good what are our odds of
catching some today can't catch them
unless we go come on let's do it all
right
[Music]
you can't be a good fisherman without
caring about the environment and
ladybird lake helped give birth to the
u.s environmental movement
this lake was created in 1960
as a lake for a power plant
but just a year later dead fish in the
hundreds maybe even thousands almost
everything in the lake had been poisoned
by insecticides like ddt
the event was used as evidence that we
were poisoning our ecosystems with ddt
and help spark ecological awareness
luckily nature has a way of bouncing
back
and this lake has become one of the
premier destinations for fishing it's a
true fishing mecca
[Music]
we're here under this bridge and there's
noise and there's traffic and there's
people
why are we starting here we have deep
water on this side
ridge pylons rock piles and a ledge and
the fish like to stage up
due to the weather conditions because of
the rocks are gonna draw some heat it's
gonna be a little bit warmer
we're hoping those big pylons will work
like heat sinks in reverse
concrete
rock
all this stuff is soaking up the heat
the the sun's out now it's soaking up
the warmth of that sun
and
especially now cold front conditions all
this concrete all this rock
is creating a hot spot and the fish like
that especially when it's cold
the weather getting cold has had a
serious effect on the fishing we've had
multiple
20-degree nights or colder under those
dropping water temperatures the fish get
lethargic they shut down they slow down
sort of like us humans in cold weather
but unlike us
they also lose their appetite got more
of a rocky spot here
and there goes one
good put the fish on oh it's a good one
that's a good one too
he's coming up he's coming up he's
coming
[Music]
up god
look at that
nice beautiful texas largemouth
unfortunately
only about two pounds
two pounds is close to the average
weight of a largemouth
average length
a little more than 12 inches long
but a big largemouth can weigh 20 pounds
and grow to well over two feet in length
the best part about it right here
letting it go for another day
even in this lake structure counts so
duke has put us on top of an underwater
feature he calls the hump
this is a hump right here
so we're in the hump right now
that one
another largemouth bass see how white he
is been deep
even though it's small it's a good
indication of what's going on today if
you look at that fish he's real pale
real white real light colored
best caught mid depth can look pale
the bite came in the middle of the water
column the water column is from
the surface of the water
all the way down to the bottom of the
water so that water column these fish
will adjust their height
depending on their mood
when it's
good fishing and they're biting they're
up near the top they're chasing
but when it really gets tough
they suspend right in the middle of the
water column telltale sign pale fish
two words for suspended fish in cold
water not good
not good at all
it's beautiful above the water today and
i'm happy to see what this famous lake
has become
but the big bass i was hoping for
that'll have to wait for another day
well
i don't like to emit failure
but today was tough today the fish won
i didn't win today and that's okay one
of the great things about fishing is
failure brings you back for more but
cutting my losses just about dark the
good news is
i'm gonna have a couple more
opportunities to catch my other species
i mean this is a prime example of you
could be in the best place in the world
but if the weather goes south it can be
tough
[Applause]
[Music]
austin texas
i came here for a rare guadalupe bass
and i got it
i came here for a big blue catfish and i
got that one too
just one fish left on my bucket list
today i'm after the prize the smallmouth
buffalo
there's nothing small about them
and these fish are fighters that pull
like tractors once they're hooked the
good news is i've got a good friend
kevin
and he's the carp master with kevin's
help we're gonna try to catch a giant
smallmouth buffalo
kevin olivier and his carp fishing
buddies are into a kind of fishing
that's totally foreign to me
but it's perfect for catching smallmouth
buffalo
another brutally chilly morning we're at
walter e long lake we're just a 10 mile
drive from downtown austin
walter e long lake covers 1200 acres and
is up to 60 feet deep
this is going to be a real challenge for
me
smallmouth buffalo are scavengers so
even the bait is different
the bait isn't anything that you know we
actually can go to a store and buy
so this is all homemade bait absolutely
what it basically is is oats grits
and then a feeder pellet called mana
that they use to feed the calves that
it's all basically a protein-rich bait
food
that pack of oats it's giant it's huge
it it looks too big
to catch anything with it but you're not
actually catching them with that that's
right that's the attractor yeah that's
actually just a freebie so they get
around it they start sucking up food so
that's going to disintegrate that's
going to thin out right that's going to
be essentially like a pile like that
sitting on the ground but the real key
is not that but is this right exactly so
that's in there with the method when it
breaks down your hair rig falls from the
side and that's what they pick up
how's that
oh we're catching a smallmouth buffalo
today come on let's pass this thing out
let's do it enjoy it
for a bass guy like me i'm in a totally
different world
they're using three 12-foot rods at a
time with alarms that go off when a fish
touches the line
so when we actually do have a bite
we get an audio indication as well as a
visual
they can cast a hundred yards
these rods are designed to cast i've
cast a measured 174 with a bait wow
that's 170 yards not feet that's
incredible that's a mile
and all the right arm is doing is
guiding it to a 45 gotcha right yeah
wow
wow
see how far that thing went up there it
still hasn't hit yet
still up there
the cast is gonna be with this hand here
exactly so you're you're pulling down
and you're guiding out just like that
yeah
oh no
yeah no
it looks easy when they're doing it but
clearly i'm going to need way more
practice
this kind of fishing is all about
setting the trap and waiting
usually i fish around structures like
logs and rocks where the fish like to
hide but it looks like these smallmouth
buffalo are way out deep in the weeds
nothing at all for us to target and
doing nothing is exhausting
just be careful you're not sleeping with
the enemy
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
go go go go that's a joke it's a joke
i'm just joking it's a joke i got this
coolest app aren't these guys funny
like i said a different breed
[Music]
so this is why i'll never be a good
smallmouth buffalo fisherman i can't sit
still
i'm ready to move already
it's just not my personality i can't sit
still that long
let's move to this fence line down here
got me a feeling
hey what was that
i thought that was one of the carp
alarms going off i haven't seen a bite
in 12 hours i thought i heard the alarm
going off i was i was ready to throw
this ride in the water and start running
magic hour
i got to get my mitts on one of these
things man i have to i'm panicking
this fishing trip is in its 12th hour
i'm thinking big lake but try well
[Music]
oh it's a good one oh god
it feels like a gooden too man
that's a big fit it feels big
oh
i just saw it the surface what is it
i just saw it it's a surface
what is it
oh
what huh
no
no
ah it's a kitty
oh
for my heart
wow
this is a big fish but not a smallmouth
buffalo it's a catfish
barbels
barbels are bad
that's
definitely not a smallmouth buffalo yeah
if you look at that belly i'm sure
that's
that's a lot of what we've been putting
out today yeah that's all food right
there
channel catfish are the most common
catfish in the united states
they're also one of the most farmed fish
fantastic breeders and tolerant of
crowding
but after 14 hours of fishing still no
smallmouth buffalo
that's a beautiful fish
man my heart's still beating i thought
that was the one
but that is definitely not a smallmouth
buffalo
this defines fishing the highs the super
highs
of catching a giant fish and the lows
of fishing 14 hours
without a single bite i'm gonna have one
more shot to do it tomorrow
i gotta make it happen man i have to
panic setting in right now
[Music]
man here we are i'm gonna have a second
chance to catch a smallmouth buffalo i
got to get this done
different day today super cloudy super
overcast and a lot colder
call for a ride share
heads in the lake yes sir let's go
awesome
2 p.m today and i'm out of here
a flight back to my home and family so
we're cutting this real tight
another day like yesterday and i'm going
home skunked
it might be years before i get to catch
a smallmouth buffalo
[Music]
what's up man what's going on how you
doing today doing good feeling much
better about things today conditions are
very much improved
cloud yeah little bit of wind pressure's
falling
well see right there when they get out
there and they just start rolling around
you'll have little they call line bites
line bites mean fish are nearby
as they feed along the bottom fish can
bump into the line or even nibble on the
bait
which sets off the alarm
yeah well like a buffalo is a real they
feed very delicately much like you see
going on right there so it's just small
bumps not committed we're just kind of
mouthing the
oh
oh
get in here this one yeah that that's
definitely a fish
that's a big fish
that's it so union's the rod right so
yeah reel down and then use the rod to
bring them back
i literally just pulled up yeah
just ease her in rod tip all the way to
the down reel reeling and slacking then
use that rod to play her back
she will beat that reel every time oh my
god yeah when she surges let her go let
her go yeah
baldor let me see your drag
all right you're good just easy right
oh please please stay on there
god
this is literally what i came to austin
for
wow
dude look at this fight this is a
vicious vicious fight look at the power
of that i'm gonna get out there and knit
it for you
this is like reeling in a car
i got a car hooked
are you kidding me
all right so i'm gonna hold the net in
one place
because i can't swing at it right and
you play the fish to the net
let me tell you i've caught
species all over the world and this is
one of the hardest fights i've ever had
there she is right there oh my god it
looks like a decent fish
no
it's a nice fish
she's got shoulders
stay on there please stay on there stay
on there just oh my god she will stay on
there rod tip high get her nose up
[Music]
we got it did that just happened
that's heavy that's heavy
that's heavy oh
that's a big fish oh my god
that is a smallmouth buffalo
that is the finest specimen
oh my god i can't pick it up
look at that here's a nice looking
buffalo
this smallmouth buffalo weighs 48 pounds
but the biggest ever caught on a rod and
reel weighed in at 82.2 pounds
they can hit full size in just five or
six years but may live 18 years in the
wild
people spend thousands of dollars to go
to exotic places that catch giant fish
absolutely you can catch it right in
cities that's it we're we're in austin
we're on the east side of austin that's
a small mouth buffalo that is almost a
50-pound smallmouth buffalo
this is the first one i've ever caught
yeah this is a bucket list
look at that
i just caught a ginormous 48 pound
smallmouth buffalo
thank you austin
thank you texas my work here is done
almost
ready to get her back let's get her back
man all right grab the handles
wow
this is absolutely
what i've come to austin texas for the
smallmouth buffalo
another bucket list fish what a city
austin texas giant fish
doesn't get any better than that this is
amazing
[Music]
look at it
good that good are you quenched are you
no let me just hold you for a second
we don't do these kind of things in
texas
[Music]
you